[Musique]
ce soir nos mémoires du zinc sont
consacrés à laurent baffie à l'occasion
de la pièce sa pièce toc toc jouer au
palais royal
alors d'habitude on a une petite ardoise
pour mettre les daces mais il paraît que
c'est jusqu'au bout du monde voilà voilà
bon d'accord on a filmé bon soir bonsoir
alors on va parler on va parler toc mais
avant j'aimerais vérifier que vous êtes
aussi savant donc nous avons créé le
coup stocks qui est consacré aux toques
et à certains alors je vous donne cette
petite liste et je vais vous poser des
questions et vous allez à lorient n'a
dit que je trouve intéressant par
exemple la 9 la gêne aux phobies la gêne
aux fans et ce ne l'est pas dans mes
notes face à la gêne aux phobies avait
intéressant la gêne aux phobies c'est la
peur du sexe du sexe du sélectionneur
open ça arrive ah ouais ah oui ça alors
d'autres tu sont un peu dans la même là
spermato phobie la peur des graines des
germes les germes de toute sorte de gêne
pas avec pas seulement pas seulement
mais des germes la vénus traf auby ac
clp race est assez répandu chez les
hommes en fin de compte c'est la peur
des belles femmes
les belles femmes à risque existe venus
images de la belle femme et certains oui
il ya des gens qui s'autocensurent
devant de belles femmes malades
alors cette pièce bon on va dire ce
qu'il en est on le sait tous voilà des
les passions sur une selle d'attentes
ils attendent le grand spécialiste des
toques chacun a le sien et ils attendent
ils attendent il ne vient pas et ça va
permettre à cette pièce d'avoir un
rebondissement parce que on va passer de
l'aventuré individuelle à l'aventuré
collective parce que dans cette pièce
indépendamment de l'idée de top comme ça
et et j'allais presque dire le côté
presque léger on pourrait se demander ce
qu'il en est il ya quand même une morale
dans cette
nora il ya du fond et puis il ya une
construction et il ya un petit message
twist way et le message c'est s'aider
des gens sont en demande de tolérance
parce qu'ils ont un regard extérieur qui
est souvent négatif à leur endroit et là
ils se réunissent ils s'affrontent il
s'énerve il se confronte
ils se disent merci on me demande de la
tolérance à l'extérieur et entre nous on
n'est pas capable de s'en donner donc
ils vont essayer de ces deux mêmes pour
pour combler ce vide du docteur qui
n'arrivent pas à pas alors quand vous
avez écrit cette fiesta d'avoir ou
pensiez à retentissement comme ça non je
pensais que cette pièce était trop
difficile pour moi j'en ai écrit la
moitié j'ai arrêté pendant un an et demi
et elles étaient elles étaient au dessus
de mon niveau et je me suis accrochée
qui chez des amis qui m'ont motivé en
dix ans mais la laisse pas tomber l'idée
formidable et
et voilà je me suis battu pour la
terminer mais je me suis beaucoup
documenté j'avais j'ai écrit un peu avec
la peur au ventre de blessés et 2
de faire de la peine aux gens alors que
c'est un message d'empathie et de
solidarité donc je voulais pas que
l'image du comique
des bandes sur l'image de l'auteur qui
voulait bien faire pour cette pièce car
le sujet était ambitieux et ça tient
bien alors ce petit punching ball pour
matérialiser un coup de gueule en ce
moment ça manque peut-être pas les
sujets mais lequel ce soir une envie de
ne traiter montre qu il a envie de viol
est toujours le même c'est toujours des
gros problèmes avec avec l'écologie ou
live id
des chiffres alarmistes alarmant et
voilà on sait maintenant on allait on le
savait déjà depuis quelques années on
savait qu'on allait dans le mur et c'est
vraiment
une fuite en avant j'ai l'impression
qu'on est tous sur le titanic et que
leur case continue à jouer et qu'on va
tous couler en plus mais là
contrairement à l'époque ans
en 14 ils savaient pas l'info kavanagh
iceberg non nous on a l'info et on y va
tout droit
alors pour dire ce sont exactement des
chiffres qui sont sortis de l'eau cdc
dire c'est pas des organisations
écologistes qui veulent dramatiser les
chiffres officiels donc il faut
peut-être aussi les x parce que ce type
de solution la plus parce se trouvait au
niveau à diviser c'est dire que s'il ya
des pays qui ne sont pas d'accord on
pense aux états unis on pense à la chine
qui eux sont en plein développement au
pyla l'inde aux pays émergents qu'ils
attendent et vous ça fait deux siècles
que moi un frais voilà et nous on va en
croquer voilà et c'est vrai que c'est
difficile de compte tenu de ce que nous
on a fait pendant tant de temps c'est
assez difficile d'ordi dont les gammes
pour arrêter les siècles qui nous va
prendre des bains j'étais moins bien je
savoir un petit peu de flotte et alors
au quotidien ça veut dire quoi on fait
attention de la voiture qu'on comprend
on fait attention comment oui j'ai de la
panoplie du bobo un g1
un 4 4 hybride g1
mais un truc pour recycler pour faire le
compost
voilà je me renseigne un peu sur les
panneaux solaires moi j'ai une vieille
maison donc je ne peux pas mettre
récupérer l'eau de pluie pour pour pour
les toilettes mais ça ce serait la
moindre des choses que de tirer la
chasse avec de l'eau de pluie
ouais mais je vais mettre des citernes
pour arroser les plantes et géothermie
aussi essayer de récupérer la balle à la
chaleur du sol pour elle mais bon il
faut avoir l'infrastructure avec mais
c'est beaucoup d'investissement beaucoup
d'argent oui pour nom mais c'est pour ça
je dis j'ai la panoplie du bobo parce
que moi j'ai les moyens un petit peu de
m'adapter mais pour les gens qui n'ont
pas de moyens ça déculpabilise encore
plus ils ne peuvent rien faire et voilà
bon bah c'est pas très encourageantes un
sens super flippant hyper flippant et on
aura des comptes à rendre à nos gosses
ils ont mon animal bas
oui les enfants ils sont très très très
près c'est hyper flippant on va venir
alors ce coup de sifflet c'est
l'occasion pour moi d'exhumer décrété
qu'ils ne sont pas extrêmement
sympathique à langer envoie civils dont
alors c'est baffie dans la voiture balai
ces libérations
le postulat est casse-gueule adoptant
une politique du pire laurent baffie
choisi un titre délibérément désastreux
les clés de la bagnole de bailleurs de
bagnols et un slogan promotionnel non
moins dissuasif
n'y allez pas c'est une merde pour
d'abord couper l'herbe sous le pied des
futurs détracteurs et surtout inciter le
public à contrario à les découvrir à
quoi peut bien ressembler cette cata
revendiqué alors qu'est ce que ça fait
ce genre de critiques là écoutez moi je
préfère avoir des bonnes critiques que
des mauvaises critiques mais libération
est un journal qui n'a aucun crédit à
mes yeux parce qu'il met un point
d'honneur à déglinguer tout le monde et
la page culturelle de libération est une
aberration donc ces voix là c'est des
gens qui disent du mal parce que c'est
leur système de fonctionnement
comme parfois des ramadans donc donc
voilà c'est pour moi un très mauvais
journal ce que je déplore parce que
quand j'étais jeune libération s'était
pas rien moi j'ai acheté est libellé
tribunal des flagrants délits c'était un
journal formidable et c'est devenu un
mets yeux un très mauvais journal et je
pensais pas qu'un jour le se trouverait
le parisien bien meilleur que libération
enfin c'est fou il ya voilà je les
trouve et je les trouve assez mauvais et
je trouve qu'ils sont de caractère qui
re même cela dit j'ai eu des mauvaises
critiques qui étaient plus justifiées je
sais pas ce que c'est une mauvaise
critique ça ne m'a pas plu mais voilà
benon 2 voilà des proches
est ce qu'ils les sources sur ce cas
précis dès que des critiques
constructives de choses s'est dit oui
ben vi bien sûr bien sûr sur ce film oui
et puis j'ai eu aussi des critiques
excellentes et mais bon
c'est amusant de voir sur les sites
internet les critiques de ce film parce
que les gens adorent ou détestent mais
mais ils sont rarement qui est en ce
film on va finir ce miroir pour figurer
un moment d'admiration alors qu'y
avez-vous choisi d'admirer woody allen
vous dit annie hall annie hall en bas en
effet oui woody allen diane keaton alors
woody allen
je veux dire pourquoi c'est un peu
l'idiot de demander pourquoi on aime ou
violents j'aime pas tout de woody allen
et j'aime particulièrement ce film il ya
des films qui sont libérateur parce que
comme ça va arrive pour moi a été
libérateur au théâtre parce que je me
suis dit ah c'est possible vous savez il
ya des choses qui sont possibles et nous
on n'a pas d'info on sait pas et dans la
narration
quand j'ai vu un viol je me suis diam on
peut se permettre ça alors alors il peut
revenir sur les lieux de son enfance se
voir jeunes et et commenter ça avec ça
avec sa petite copine et ça m'a fasciné
et ça m'a ouvert des portes
de plus en termes d'écriture oui
d'écriture et c'est marrant parce que je
fais l'apologie d'un film que j'essaie
de vendre à tout le monde
la personne qui n'ont pas encore vu et
je trouve malgré tout que le film un peu
vieilli alors est ce que dans le
personnage de woody allen
il ya quelque chose qui vous intéresse
c'est d'abord j'adore les murgers et
puis et puis ce new yorkais jëf new
yorkais plus particulièrement
et cette autodérision et
on a beaucoup aussi conditionné dans ma
forme d'humour je pense que on peut pas
se [ __ ] de la gueule des autres si on
ne pratique pas l'auto dérision soi même
et lui sait
maître dans ce domaine est ce que vous
êtes de ceux qui attendent chaque année
parce qu'on a envie d'y aller j'ai un
petit peu décroché il ya une période où
j'ai décroché ou galettes m'emmerdait
hannah et ses soeurs tout ça quand ils
faisaient des soupes berman ça
m'emmerdait donc et puis après il se
remit un petit peu mais ce qui est
étonnant c'est qu'effectivement avec
woody allen on a tous une histoire un
petit peu mots comme ça qui nous déçoit
puis qu'après un ou deux après l'homme
invoqué un film par an oui une capacité
à tourner on voit en tout cas voilà
woody allen
annie hall pour le plaisir et puis aussi
aller au delà de ce plaisir là et
s'apercevoir que woody allen nous
apprend qu on peut écrire différemment
voilà cette caméra qui signifie que
notre invité va nous emmener dans un
moment d'intimité s'il s'appelle une
vidéo intime au choix qu'est ce que
laurent baffie ou laurent baffie envie
de nous emmener
il ya un truc quand on est enfant et un
truc est intéressant c'est qu'on vit des
choses sans les comprendre et on
comprend ce parfois beaucoup plus tard
des années plus tard et quand j'étais
gosse j'allais souvent en italie en
vacances et j'avais
j'avais 5 ans 4 5 ans et j'étais déjà
attiré par les jolies femmes
je me souviens je jouais dans l'eau
ballon avec des très jolies femmes des
filles sublimes depuis deux italiennes
les italiennes de 20 ans et tout et je
voyais mes parents les amis des parents
qui rigolaient année aura ça va échouer
je comprenais pas et je comprenais pas
pourquoi il y avait cette connivence
comme ça ils se poussent du coude en dix
ans il a la chance le pied tout est
quelque part j'étais fier parce que je
comprenais sans comprendre tout mais
mais je savais déjà tout c'était une
sorte de prescience des choses le pré
sence de quoi de la sensualité du charme
ou de son propre charme et de
l'attirance non parce que moi j'étais un
gosse mignon donc donc voila et j'avais
la chance d'être je voyais les adultes
bavay parce que j'étais entouré de deux
puits sublime et je comprenais sans
comprendre et ça je trouve que c'est
emblématique de plein de souvenirs qu'on
se fait étant jeune où on vit des
situations fortes sans les comprendre et
après on recolle le pulse plus tard on
se dit ah d'accord
voilà pourquoi là on m'a dit ça j'ai
fait ça on a compris ça et donc et ces
moments là quoi est-ce que ça fait
regarder ses enfants différemment 11 il
se passe des choses pour eux qu'ils
comprennent qu'ils comprennent pas est
ce qu'on s'imagine on se projette
quand on voit nos enfants vivre ce qu'on
a vécu on
un regard complice et ça nous renvoie
notre enfance bien sûr donc on parlait
avec vous laurent baffie de toc toc au
palais royal
alors bon voilà c'est tout vert et au bo
fois pressé vous quand même parce que la
location est assez serré là on a fist
est un plaisir
moi aussi partagez merci beaucoup
[Musique]